shouldn't the rest of the government be
begging nasa for money
well this is the old question you see it
it's not do space exploration or provide
clean water for people who don't have it
or provide education for girls and women
so that they raise the standard of
living and improve the quality of life
for all citizens everywhere it's not one
or the other it's not nasa or build a
new baseball stadium you have to do
everything all at once right also
doesn't nasa investing in nasa then
literally has a very good return right
yeah in terms of the money the
government spends and it's not very much
it's less than one penny of your tax
dollar that goes to next yeah 0.4
percent uh and furthermore also in
addition to continue
uh the current number is three dollars
and sixty cents for every dollar that
goes into nasa you get three dollars and
sixty cents back that's pretty good
that's really good it's very good some
people will argue that highways are
slightly larger but highways in general
do not lead to innovation the way space
exploration does and it's something for
the future it's it's about the future
innovation is what's going to drive the
economy
oh